the marvel cinematic universes first
post-credits scene almost looked into
the franchise's future way into the
future at the 2019 Saturn Awards Marvel
Studios head honcho Kevin Feige appeared
in a brief video clip to share an
alternate version of Iron Man's famous
stinger with the crowd it's probably for
the best that they went with a
simplified take because if they had used
the alternate Marvel fans heads would
have exploded the clip is part of an
apparent treasure trove of deleted
scenes from the MCU that will be made
available to the Infinity Saga box set
and it features a very different version
of the speech Nick Fury gives to Tony
Stark
after surprising the billionaire at his
home the original post-credit scene of
Iron Man introduced audiences to fury
include them in that yes all these
Marvel movies were going to be connected
mr. stark you become part of a bigger
universe you just don't know it
Marvel Comics diehards went absolutely
bananas over the reveal of Jax and his
fury and the taste possibility of an
Avengers movie but the alternate version
that Feige screened for fans would have
had them freaking out exponentially
harder here's the alternate line of
dialogue that would have changed
everything
both whites and assorted mutants weren't
enough wait what the implication of the
existence of spider-man and the x-men in
the MCU is very first film the less
would have blown fans out of their seats
fury continues I have to deal with a
spoiled brat who doesn't play well with
others and wants to keep all his toys to
himself the who the hell are you
exchanged between Fury and Stark is the
same as in the final version but there's
an additional exchange that is also new
Oh what are we avenging whatever the
hell we want the priests a cobia chords
era was such an innocent time but back
to the Furies mind-blowing opening line
remember at that time the film rights to
the x-men were owned by Fox Studios who
has been busily cranking out successful
films based on these properties for the
past eight years the rights to
spider-man were held
Sony Pictures which has fielded an
immensely successful film trilogy based
on the wall crawler and was a few years
away from rebooting the property of
course the last few years have made this
alternate version of the Iron Man
stinger scene appeared downright
prophetic following the striking of a
shared custody deal between Sony and
Marvel spider-man has enjoyed a three
year five picture run in the MCU
negotiations to reap the deal have
recently hit an impasse making the
cinematic future of the character a bit
unclear but in 2008 the idea that Spidey
could ever appear in a film from scrappy
upstart Marvel Studios was town right
laughable likewise the formerly Fox
owned properties are now free and clear
for use in the MCU but it took to
seismic developments for that to happen
Marvel Studios and Fox Studios were both
purchased by the same parent company the
increasingly monolithic Disney in 2009
the House of mouse purchased Marvel
Studios for just over four billion
dollars which turned out to be a pretty
sweet deal for a production house that
would eventually turn the MCU into the
highest-grossing film franchise in
history then earlier this year Disney
acquired the film and television assets
of Fox for an eye-popping seventy one
point three billion dollars while one of
the primary purposes of the acquisition
was to secure fox's incredibly deep
television library to bolster its
upcoming streaming service disney plus
it goes without saying that bringing all
those legacy characters home to Marvel
with some pretty fantastic icing
slathered liberally on that cake but in
2008 there would have been no reason to
think that the x-men and The Avengers
could ever play in the same cinematic
sandbox at any rate it's fascinating to
see what might have been and even more
so to think what else Feige and company
will be dragging out of their vault to
share with us for the infinity sagas box
set release it has yet to be announced
when the collection will hit store
shelves the will be all over it when it
does check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about the MCU are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]